Bonsoir c'est Norman pour une petite vidéo au calme.
Je voulais juste parler d'un petit
délire, c'est ces potes, tu vois,  ces amis qu'on aime bien mais qui parfois sont
un peu agaçants tu vois, voire un peu
énervants. On a un peu envie de leur mettre
des petites baffes sur la tête
Bruits de baff fait par la bouche de cet individus x3                                          Ces potes agaçants (des fois)
Alors déjà on a tous ces fameux potes
qui sont en couple, et sous simple
prétexte qu'ils sont en couple,
ils font plus aucune sortie c'est-à-dire que pour eux l'amusement entre amis
ça n'existe plus.
"Avec les autres on va en boîte. Vous venez avec nous ?"
"Euh nous on va rentrer parce que Céline est fatiguée"
"Allez, venez avec nous !"
"Non c'est gentil mais on a déjà fait une grosse soirée la semaine dernière,
on a du mal à s'en remettre."
"Ah ouais ? Vous avez fait quoi ?"
"Bah on est allé au cinéma. (EXTRAORDINAIRE)
On a vu un film en 3D."
Après on a tous cette pote,
des fois tu sais pas si c'est ta pote
ou si c'est ta prof de français
"Et donc hier j'étais avec la sœur à Nico..."
"On dit pas la sœur à Nico,
on dit la sœur de Nico."
"Ouais enfin bon bref en tout cas on mangeait des zharicots et à
un moment donné..."
"Ouais par contre on dit pas des sharicots, on dit les haricots. Merci."
"Ok attends j'ai juste une question :
l'expression c'est ferme ta gueule ou
ferme ta GROSSE gueule ?"
"Ben normalement l'expression de base c'est ferme ta gueule. Y a pas de...
Là y a rien de spécial..."
"Ferme ta gueule j'aime bien ouais, (petit rire)
ça c'est efficace !
Et ouais donc j'étais en train de
manger des zharicots et..."
Tu sais parfois tu es content parce que tu as un nouveau vêtement, qui correspond un peu à ton style,
tu es un peu le seul à l'avoir.
Tu as toujours un pote qui comprend pas ça, qui va au magasin et qui achète le même.
Vraiment le même, identique.
- "Ça va Akim ?"                                           - "Ça va mec ?"
"Tu as pris le même manteau que moi ?"
"Oh c'est bon ça va, c'est pas grave !"  "Mais tu as pas ton propre style ? Tu as pas envie d'acheter
des vêtements... ?"  "Si mais c'est juste que celui là il m'allait bien c'est tout..."
"Il y a 10 000 manteaux sur Terre, le mec il prend le même manteau que moi ! Avoue que tu as..."
GROS BLANC
"C'est le hasard !"
Il y a ce pote avec qui tu ne pourras jamais avoir une discussion discrète.
La discrétion c'est pas une de ses
compétences.
"Eh, discret hein, tu te retournes discrètement,
mais derrière toi il y a une fille...
Elle est trop belle magnifique, magnifique. Tu fais discret hein ?"
"Excusez-moi...faîtes voir... Elle est pas mal hein !"
...
Quand tu rencontres une fille qui te plaît, avec qui tu as un peu envie de sortir,
et que c'est pas encore tout à fait fait, tu vois, je pense qu'il ne faut pas tout de suite
la présenter à tes potes.
Parce qu'il y en a toujours un qui comprend pas, qui comprends pas cette démarche...
"Une nouvelle connaissance...Sarah." "Enchantée" "Salut Sarah !" "Salut !"
"Tu viens d'où Sarah ?"
"Dix-huitième et toi ?" "Ben j'habite aussi dans le dix-huitième !" "Où ça ?" "Ben pas loin dans le dix-huitième !"
"Tchao Norman !" "Allez salut Norman !" "Merci beaucoup hein !"
Après il y a aussi ce pote tactile. Lui, il ne peut pas s'empêcher de te parler
sans te touche, sans te palper le corps.
"Heyyy ça va Norman ? Qu'est-ce que tu as fait ce week end ? On ne t'a pas vu !" "Ben j'étais..." "Ben alors, ça va ?
Tu as l'air un peu pâlot, qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ?"
"Rien, ça va"
Sauf que je me disais que le jour où ce mec va rencontrer un autre mec tactile,
ça va être un petit peu chelou.
"Alors, ça va la famille ?" "Et toi ?"
"Les frères et sœurs, tout ça !" "Ça fait plaisir de te voir !" "Ben carrément mon gars c'est cool !"
C'est bon tu as un petit peu de pep là, c'est bon ça, j'aime bien, j'aime bien...
CHANSON LOVER (et moment chelou)
Il y a certains potes,
tu n'as pas besoin de leur dire de se
mettre à l'aise quand tu les invites chez toi.
Naturellement, ils sont
déjà un peu comme chez eux.
"Lucas, excuse-moi je ne t'ai même pas dit, évidemment mets-toi à l'aise hein, fais comme chez toi !"
"Ben évidemment !
Je repeins juste vite fait le salon parce que je n'aime pas trop le blanc, ça fait un peu hôpital.
Je préfère quand c'est pêchu.
Ça ne te dérange pas ? Et juste...enlève tes chaussures quand tu rentres dans le salon, c'est...c'est la base...le minimum. Merci.
En tout cas, qu'ils soient agaçants ou pas, les poteaux, les amis,
heureusement qu'ils sont là, parce que
quand tu es en galère, quand tu n'as plus rien, que tu as besoin de quelqu'un...
Ben c'est sur eux que tu peux compter !
"Allô ? Ouais mec je t'appelle parce que demain je déménage,
et j'aurais voulu savoir si tu pouvais venir m'aider."
"Attends, c'est toi qui as mis la vidéo sur Youtube sur les potes agaçants ?"
Non. Enfin si, si, mais euh..."
Allô ? Allô ?
Love.